Asam brother are women allowed to pray
in the
mosque the sister has a question that
are women allowed to pray
namas there is no verse in the Holy
Quran which prohibits a woman from
praying in the mosque neither is there
any authentic Hadith which says that a
woman cannot pray in a mosque or go to a
mosque in fact there are several Hadith
which speak the opposite if you read s
bukari volume number one the last Hadith
Hadith number 832 of the book of
characteristics of
Salah which is chapter number 84 it says
that when your wives asked to go to the
mosque do not forbid them it's mentioned
in s bukari volume number one the book
of characteristics of Salah chapter
number 80 Hadith 824 it says that when
the woman ask you to go to the mosque at
night allow them even at night when they
ask you to go to the mosque the S bukari
volume 1 Hadith number 824 says that you
should allow them to go to the MOs this
is also mentioned say Muslim it's say
Muslim Point number one in the book of
Salah chapter number 175 Hadith number
881 it says that Abu Hara may Allah be
pleased with him he said that the best
Row for the men are the first row and
the worst are the last rows
the best rol for the woman are the last
roles and the worst are the first roles
indicating that men and women pray
together in the mosque and when they
pray together the best Row for the men
is the first row the best for the women
is the last row the worst for the men is
the last row and ver for the women of
the first row there are several Hadith
if you read say Muslim one number
one in the book of Salah chapter 177
Hadith number 884 it says that do not
prevent the Servants of Allah subhanahu
wa tala to go to the
mosque say Muslim volume one book of
Salah chapter number
177 Hadith number 891 it says that do
not take away the share of the mosque of
the woman that means during the time of
the Prophet the woman did go to the Mosk
and Prophet never prevented them from
entering the mosque but whenever women
enter the the mosque there should be
equal and separate facility in the
mosque there should be no intermingling
of the Sexes like how you have in the
other place of worship otherwise people
will go more for East teasing than to
worship Allah subhana tala separate
entrance separate woo facility separate
place for prayer and but natural a woman
cannot stand in front of the men
otherwise the men will concentrate more
on the women than on Allah subhana tala
equal but separate facilities if if it's
side then preferably a partition or they
should pray behind equal but separate
facilities if you analyze if you go
Saudi Arabia the women allowed in the
mosque even in the har har Sharif the M
Haram in Makkah and M in Madina the
women allowed in the mosque you go to
America women allowed in the mosque you
go to UK women allowed in the mosque you
go to South Africa women allowed in the
mosque women are allowed in the mosque
in almost all parts of the world it's
only in India that most of the mosque do
not give permission for the women to
enter but alhamdulillah there are few
mos in Bombay which I know of which do
allow women to enter and when i' had
been to K last year they told me that
there were no less than 500 mosque in
Kerala alone which had separate
facilities for the woman to
pray so inshallah I believe that all
those are Trustees of the MOs even they
refer to the had and they do not prevent
the female Servants of Allah subhana wa
taala from in the Mosk even in Bombay
hope that answer the
question assalamu alikum my name is shik
Ahmed working profession and my question
to brother Zakir is what is the
significance of raising our
hands while saying T during Salah the
brother has a question that what is the
significance of raising the hands when
we say t in
Salah hands are a symbol
of power and
force when we Muslims raise the hand in
Salah it mainly signifies three things
first we are submitting to Allah subhana
wa tala by raising our
hands we are
signifying so as to say that oh Allah I
submit to
you like how when we want a person to
surrender we say hands up you know
police says hands up to the to the
robber indirectly telling him that you
surrender so when we do hands up we are
surrendering to Allah subhana
tala and
simultaneously when we raise our hands
it also signifies the glorification of
Allah subhana wa tala by action as well
as by words Allah abbar Allah is the
greatest and besides that when we raise
our hands and fold it over the chest we
are giving a signal that I am facing my
back toward the worldly Affairs and
giving up everything to con concentrate
on the worship of Allah subhana tala
hope that answer the
questional alikum my name is yusu Desai
I'm retired government official my
question is at what time in the life of
holy prophet Salah was ordained by
Almighty and what are the achievements
of shab Mir these two questions I think
are related therefore I put the
questions brother has a question that at
what time
exact date he
wants was a beloved Prophet Ed to offer
Salah and what the significance of Miraj
in connection with Salah brother exact
date day like how we know when he died
when he was born we don't know but it
was towards the early part of his
prophethood because there are hadiths
telling us that how did Archangel
Gabriel show him to offer Salah what he
did he put his foot in the ground and
then water gush forth from the ground
and Archangel Gabriel he showed to the
prophet how to do wo and he showed him
how to do Salah same thing the prophet
came home and repeat in front of his
wife B Khadijah may Allah be pleased
with her so it was ordained in the early
part of his prophethood regarding how
many Salah exact to offer and regarding
second part of the question
that which is indication is given in the
Holy Quran inah is chapter number 17
verse number one which says that the
prophet was transported from mid Haram
to m
and then it talks about the and the
descriptionari and the that how he me
and he met the other prophets M alham
Isa alham Moses peace be upon Him Jesus
peace be upon Him Abraham peace be upon
him and how Allah subhana wa taala
ordained the prophet that the Muslim
should offer 50 times Salah when he came
down M Alam tokari it says that 50 will
be too difficult for the Muslims go and
ask Allah subhana request him to make
make it less he goes when the Salah is
made less again he comes back again the
prophet goes to make it less and finally
in the ending the Salah is made to five
times the Salah Allah subhana tala
agrees and says to the prophet that
offer five times Salah and then he says
that this five time will be equivalent
to 50 times of Salah
hope alikum brother I'd like to ask you
why aren't all our prayers or
supplications answered or fulf filled by
Allah subhana
tala the sisters posed a question that
why are all our prayers not answered by
Allah subhana wa tala sister the answer
to this question is given in the Holy
Quran in Surah Bak chapter number two
verse number 216 which says but it is
possible that you may dislike a thing
which is good for you and you may love a
thing which is bad for you for Allah
knoweth everything and you know not
Allah says in the Holy Quran it's
possible that you may dislike a thing
which is good for you and you may love a
thing which is bad for you for example
if a very religious Pious person he
prays to Allah subhana wa taala that
please give me a motorcycle so it will
help me in traveling and his prayer is
not answered people say what a Pious
person religious person why is this
prayer not being answered Allah subhana
tala knows that if he acquires a m cycle
he may have an accident and he may get
crippled as the Holy Quran says that you
may love a thing which is bad for you
Allah knows you know not once there was
a very rich
businessman who
was going to catch a flight to London to
click a
deal which would fetch him a profit of
more than a billion rupees when he's
traveling towards the airport
unfortunately there is an unusual
traffic jam on the
road and he's unable to reach the
airport on time by the time he reaches
the airport the flight has already taken
off he misses the
flight he says in a very sorrowful tone
this is the worst thing that has
happened to me in my life while going
back home on the radio in the car he
hears the latest news that the flight
which you are supposed to catch which
was going to London it crashed and all
the passengers in that flight they died
so the businessman says this is the best
thing that happened to me in my
life a few moments ago he was cursing
the traffic jam because of the traffic
jam he lost billions of rupees a few
moments later on he thanked the traffic
jam because it saved his life as the
Quran says you may dislike a thing which
is good for you Allah knows you know not
Allah knows that the life of the
businessman was much more precious than
the billions of rupees he was about to
ear whatever you ask Allah subhana wa
ta'ala many times he does not fulfill
your prayers he does not answer your
prayers and it's mentioned in the Holy
Quran in Surah sh 42 verse number 27
that if Allah were to increase
if
Allah were to increase the provisions of
his servants they would surely
transgress all Bonds on the
earth for Allah gives it to them in due
measures and he knows what he
gives the Holy Quran says in Surah bakar
2 vers number 186 that when they ask
thee concerning me tell them I am close
to them I'm very close to them and I
listen to every supplicant of my servant
the message repeated in Surah 40 verse
number 60 that the Lord says ask me and
I will answer your prayer the Holy Quran
says that Allah says ask me and I will
answer your prayer people may think that
this verse isn't fulfilled if your
prayers aren't answered actually if you
analyze Allah subhana waala is answering
your prayer by not answering
it because he knows what what is good
and bad for
you there are some people who may say
that we see many
unbelievers many unpas people who pray
to false god and they lead a very
luxurious
life these unbelievers they pray to
false god for money and they get wealth
Allah subhah wa ta'ala even if these
unpas unbelievers they pray to false god
he fulfills their material desires
because he knows that what they asking
for is actually going to cause them more
loss in the long run in the year after
is going to cause nothing but loss the
True Believers are those
irrespective whether they're rich or
poor whether in good times or bad times
they yet believe in Allah subhana tala
as the Holy Quran says in Surah n
24:37 That by The Believers who neither
traffic or merchandise can divert from
remembering Allah subhana wa ta'ala from
establishing prayers from giving regular
charity from humbling themselves for
these people only fear that day on which
hearts and eyes will be transformed they
only fear the the day of judgment which
is the final day of accounting a True
Believer always says alhamdulillah
irrespective whatever happens
alhamdulillah means praise be to Allah
even if he goes in loss he says
alhamdulillah because he has faith in
Allah that if Allah allowed this loss to
be incurred it has to be beneficient for
him in the long run in short a True
Believer believes in Allah that whatever
happens happens for Good Hope to answer
the
question alikum my name is n aam and I'm
an engineer by profession my question is
very close to the question by from
Sister side in the beginning that the
jum
which is not a part of the Salah is it
compulsory to deliver in the Arabic
language the brother POS a question that
is it compulsory to deliver the Jumba in
Arabic there are difference of opinion
among the scholars but with the
exception of IM Malik may Allah be
pleased with him all the other Scholars
including Imam Abu hanifah Imam
Shafi Imam Ahmed B hbal and all the
other Scholars most of them may Allah be
peace with them all but the minimum
requirement of Jumba that is praising
Allah subhana wa tala sending the
blessings on the prophet and the Arabic
verses to be recited in the Jumba they
should at least be in Arabic the
remaining part can be in any language
there is not a single authentic Hadith
in which the prophet said that the Juma
kba cannot be given in any other
language but but I do know that the
prophet always gave the kba in Arabic
and the reason was because the people of
Arabia at that time they only understood
Arabic so because they understood Arabic
the prophet always gave the kba in
Arabic but no Hadith says that he
prevented people from giving theba in
any other language or he told other
people not to give the kba in any other
language the reason the Juma kba is
there is
because to guide the congreg
ation towards the Commandments of Allah
subhana wa tala and the
prophet as well as to give them some
guidance about the latest happenings in
the community in short it is to guide
and give advice to the Muslim
umah it will be illogical to say that I
will give guidance to a person in a
language he doesn't understand so but
naturally when we give guidance you
should give in the language he
understands if you go to America in
America they have the jum English many
MOS many MOS throughout the world they
have kba in the local language in
America in Canada in UK in South Africa
many MOS have the kba in English if you
go to Arabia the Arab countries since
the people understand Arabic the kba
there is in
Arabic but last month when i' had been
to Kuwait
though the majority people of Kuwait
understand Arabic yet a few mosques had
the kba in English a few mosques had the
kba in uru a few MOS even had in
malyalam and other languages this the
government has given special permission
so that the
expatriates those people who are not the
residents of Kuwait those who come from
outside Kuwait for employment in Kuwait
They will receive guidance in the local
language so kba can be given any
language but the condition is that
praising Allah subhana wa ta'ala should
be in
Arabic the blessings in working on
Prophet should be in
Arabic and the Dua that you have should
be in Arabic which can consist even of
few verses few lines which you can also
translate inba so there's no harm at all
in fact people should be encouraged so
that they get guidance it should be
given in the local language except the
few part I mentioned it should be in
Arabic which can also be translated it's
in India most parts of India and those
MOS controlled by the Indian immigrants
abroad where the kba is only in Arabic a
few moth have a prba a new thing prba
which is the local language a few moth
have translation of theba after jum
Salah therefore I request and I pray to
Allah subhana wa ta'ala that may he also
give hia to the people in India that
even in India we have theba in the local
language so that we get guidance every
week during
Juma brother
zamik my name is Abdul Kad I'm a
businessman from social worker as you
said we Muslims pray five times Allah
tala and you explain in Mir events how
five times PR PRI was fixed but we see
some of they do three times a day is it
is there any justification doing
so the brother has a question that as I
mention that how five times is
compulsory and even mention the Quran
some people offer three times Salah is
it Justified according to the Quran you
should pray five times every day but
there are certain concession given to
you you the vers I recited in which five
time is compulsory Surah Hood 11:
114 Surah is 17 verse 78 Surah T 20 vers
130 and Sur room 30 verse 17 and 18 if
you read these verses these verses
Clearly say you should pray five times
but Allah subhana tala has given you
concession certain times as it mention n
chter 4 verse number 101 that when you
travel you can shorten your Salah as I
mentioned four of Z and is can be short
in two raat and when you're traveling
since it will be inconvenient you can
join the Z and the Salah and if you want
you can join the m and the is Salah so
when people join it becomes thce so when
you're traveling anyone does I've have
got no objection there are even Hadith
showing that in times of difficulty
there's ath inkari which says that it
was raining very heavily
and people could not after M Salah come
again for the is Salah so the prophet
joined so during any
Calamity and any difficulty the prophet
has given permission that you can join
but I do know there are some people who
say who I have to go to office therefore
I will join my assar and Z together just
for small Petty things you want to go
shopping you want to go shopping and
then I'll Take 5 hours for shopping so I
miss my Salah so I joined my Z and so
this is not allowed while traveling and
in times of actual difficulties the
prophet has given you permission
otherwise under normal circumstances you
should pray five times Salah every day
hope to answer the
question the S has a question
that thean how did it originate in which
land and how did it take place sister it
took place in the land of Arabia city of
Madina and given in the Hadith that we
have that when the MOS was constructed
the prophet and the sahabas were
discussing how to call the people some
people suggested the drum beat some
people suggested The Conch and various
suggestions were given the Hadith says
that a person he in his vision
he heard the words of the Adan which I
recited in my talk by human voice which
came to the knowledge of the prophet and
the prophet agreed that whatever he
heard the words are very good and
there's no better way of calling the
people to Salah this way and using the
human voice that's when the prophet
commanded that when you call people for
Salah use your human voice instead of
the other things which people use like
drum trumpet Etc and it was in Madina
hope to answer the question
[Applause]
we would now be starting the questions
on the slips too the procedure would be
such one question I would put now on the
slip then on the mic my right hand side
again on the slip then on the mic on the
left hand side again on the slip then on
the sister and such manner in a
clockwise
rotation the question is from Brother
Abdullah he asked there are several
methods of Performing Salah
are all of them acceptable or is there
only one common method of offering Salah
the brother as the question that there
are several ways of offering Salah and I
do know of that are all of them
acceptable are all of them collect or
there's only one common
method if you go to the market you will
find hundreds of book on describing the
method of how to perform
Salah most of them they contain few or
more unauthentic
Hadith most of them there is only one
common method of offering Salah as a
beloved Prophet said it's mentioned in s
bukari volume number one in the book of
Adan chapter number 18 Hadith number 604
as well as s bukari volume number n
Hadith 352 the prophet said pray as you
have seen me praying when you offer
Salah you should offer Salah as our
beloved Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam offered Salah and no
other way so where it comes to the major
of the Salah like where to keep your
hands how to stand inam in r in the
various posters all these there is only
one style only one method which is
mentioned and given in the had if you
refer to them there are a few options
which a person has for example what you
recite in Ru says that sometime the
prophet
recited that glory be to Allah who
Supreme sometime he recited
sub that glory be to Allah who Supreme
and praise be to him so there are a few
duas various different duas which the
prophet recited in Ru in where a person
has an option for example I told in V
you have to offer all raat that is the
Commandment sometime Prophet offered one
sometimes five sometimes seven most of
the time three raat so there are options
in certain things mainly in recitation
in Ru in sud Etc but the major part the
posture how you stand how do you sit how
do you bow how do you prostrate
everything is only one common method
which is given in the
had the best book that I can recommend
which is available and which is very
concise small book and which contains
authentic Hadith is the book the guide
to Salah by m s if people have more time
and they want to read a bigger book A
book which gives more minute details how
do you go for fud what part of the body
you touch first how do you get up all
the minute details you can refer to the
book The Prayer of the Prophet from the
beginning to the end as if you see it by
shikh Muhammad Nas Al albani sh albani
it gives the quotation of sth Etc you
can refer to this book but as the
question is that's for the few
recitation the major part of Salah is
only one type and if you want to read
these books you can refer to the library
of the Islam Research Foundation where
the books are available my name is
jagendra sidhu I don't have a Islamic
background but even my question is not
exactly concerned with Sal can I ask
that uh we allow you questions on the
topic or connected to the topic but I
actually I have been looking for people
to ask this question I have not been
able to as an exception you that's why I
came interest would uh allow you a
question that's actually two yes oh
we'll allow you one question we made one
exception don't
let okay the basic question which I've
been asking I met couple of my Muslim
friends and also I went to Muhammad Ali
and ask some imams also I as far as I
know the meanings of Al Lam or t or
hamim all these are have not been
expounded by the prophet or have they
been told to
the nearer disciples or is it just not
known or is it not just not told or is
it nobody knows what is
it it's a basic thing because it starts
from there the Quran basically starts
from there Al lamim and then everything
starts the brother has asked a question
and he asked to many imams and many
Muslims didn't get the answer that what
is the meaning of alif lam me these
abbreviated
letters for the complete detail I I
think the answer is given in one of my
cassettes it's given the in detail but
since we have all the question I'll just
give in brief that these abbreviated
letters which come in the beginning of
certain suras it's there in the
beginning of 29
suras even the Arabic alphabets if you
count Al along with ha there are 29
Arabic letters and in the beginning of
29 suras you find that these letters
come sometime a single s Moon sometime
in twos
H sometime in three letters Al L
sometime in four sometime in
five there are various books written on
this subject volumes and volumes of
books that what does it mean some people
say
that it is a short form of Allah subhana
wa tala some people some people said
that it is the signature of Allah
subhana tala some people say that it is
used for rhyming some people say that
archangel gabri
used it to attract the attention of
prophet Muhammad sahi wasallam who used
it to attract the attention of the
people who read the Quran various
various hundreds you'll find but the
most authentic and the correct is that
these abbreviated
letters actually if you analyze they
come in beginning of various suras is a
challenge to the humanity there's a
verse in the Holy Quran several times
the Holy Quran says it gives a challenge
to humanity that try and produce a
Quran a work like the Holy Quran in
Surah is 17: 88 even if Jin and Men got
together they will not be able to
produce a recit like the Quran the Holy
Quran says in Surah chapter 52 verse 34
that you will not be able to produce a
work like the Quran in Surah Hood 11
verse number 13 it
says that if you are in doubt try and
produce 10 suras like the Holy
Quran in in Sur unus chapter 10 verse 38
it says try and produce a Surah like the
Quran and the challenge gets simpler and
simpler and the final challenge is given
in Surah Bak chapter 2 verse 23 and 24
which
says and if you in doubt as what we have
revealed to our servant from time to
time then try and produce a Surah
somewhat similar to
it
and call forth your helpers and
Witnesses if there is any besides Allah
if your doubts are but
true and if you
cannot and of you
cannot then fear the fire whose fuel
shall be man and stone which is prepared
for those who reject Faith Allah subhana
wa tala gives the challenge to the human
beings to try and produce a work like
the Holy Quran so Allah when he says
Alam
[Music]
he's giving indication to the Arabs the
Quran was revealed in Arabia so it had
to be an Arabic language and the local
language of the people out there was
Arabic so Allah indirectly is telling
that you people Arabic is your
language how you say A B C D English
same way Al L me is your language with
these letters which you're so proud of
because when the Quran was revealed the
were very proud of their language Arabic
was at it Zenit at it speak the thing
that the Arabs were most proud of was
their language it was the age of
literature and poetry they were
excellent in literature and poetry so
Allah says that these are your letters
with your letters which you're so proud
of I have
produced this Holy Quran he challenges
all the human beings if they want they
can take the help of Jin also anyone
besides Allah to try and produce a
single Surah like the Holy Quran certain
Surah of the Holy Quran are very small
three verses and the shortest contain 10
words so Allah is challenging them that
try and produce a Surah somewhat similar
to the Holy Quran so when Allah says
alif l ha after this wherever you read
whenever it occurs in the Holy Quran
after that immediately there is a praise
of Holy Quran for example in Surah bakar
as you said starting of the Quran not
starting of the Quran starting of B it
says this is a book in which there is
guidance without doubt for all those who
have faith all those have tawa who have
Im so whenever these abbreviated letters
come after that immediately there is
praising of the Holy Quran so whenever
these letters are occurring in the Holy
Quran it's a reminder to the human being
that this is Allah's Cam and reminder
for the challenge that try and produce a
work like the Holy Quran you will not be
able to do it no one has been able to do
it so far many people tried many
non-muslim tried but they feel miserably
no one has been able to do it and no one
inshallah will be ever be able to do it
till
[Applause]
eternity the question from the
slip why is the method of Performing
Salah for man and woman
different
the question POS was that why is the
method for performing
Salah of man and woman different as I
mentioned there are several books
available in the
market describing the method of offering
Salah and most of them have separate
chapters of how a woman should perform
Salah and how a man should offer Salah
and the posters are
different
in fact there is not a single authentic
Hadith which says that the woman should
offer Salah different than the men
there's not a single authentic
Hadith in fact if you read s bukari Vol
number one in the book of
characteristics of Salah chapter number
63 AB may Allah be pleased with her she
sat in tah like the men and she was of
women B vered in religious
Affairs there are several Hadith
narrated by AA by the other wives of the
prophet and other lady companions may
Allah be peace with them all mentioned s
bukari say Muslim and various s Hadi but
none of them say that there is a
particular different method and
different postures for a man and woman
to offer Salah the answer is very
clearly given as I mentioned ear ear in
s bukari volume number one in the book
of Adan chapter number 18 Hadith number
604 and S bukari volume number n Hadith
number 352 the prophet said pray as you
have seen me praying so the men and
women should offer Salah in the same
postures and same way hope the answer
question my question is is it necessary
to offer Salah only can't we pray to
Allah in our own way and will it be
accepted by Allah and did the earlier
prophets pray like how we do and did
they pray five times a
day the brothers asked a question that
should we offer the Salah in the same
way as told in the Quran and Hadith can
we offer in our own way and did the
earlier prophets offer in the same way
as this
Salah the second part of the question
all the prophets of Allah subhana wa
tala offer
Salah and all of them at least did the
sujud the main part of Salah but all the
prophet may not have offered exactly the
same way as we offer today as the Holy
Quran says in Sur ma 5 vers number three
on this day have I completed a religion
for you and I've complete my favor on
you and I've chosen for you Islam after
the Quran was revealed the whole Dean
was made complete before that the
prophet did offer Salah they did do
sujud but everything else was not in the
same form may be somewhat similar as I
give examples what mentioned in the
bible Etc somewhat similar but may not
be the exact form regarding a first part
of the question that can we offer in any
way like we
want why should we offer in the same way
I gave you the reasons why we offer
Salah the way we offer Salah there are
social
benefits the increase of Brotherhood is
there Unity is there equality is there
if you say Okay I want to offer my house
only sitting on the chair all these
benefits you not derive social equality
Brotherhood love between the human
beings the spiritual benefits and
various benefits the full talk which I
gave major part of it contain the
benefits if you off in your style you
will not derive all these benefits and
this is the way taught to us by Allah
subhana tala and his Prophet if you
think you're better than the prophet you
can try it but you'll
fail as the Holy Quran says in Al Imran
chap 3 vers
54 the unbelievers plotted and plan
Allah to plan Allah is the bless of
planner so Allah has shown you the way
this is the best if you think you're
better than Allah subhana tala I want to
improve on him you can try it you'll
fail Allah gives the challenge try and
produce a Surah better than the Quran
people have tried their field so if
anyone thinks he's better than Allah and
the prophet is as good as K that's why
the unbelievers they pray the way they
pray but anyone who has faith in the
Holy Quran and Allah subhana and the
prophet they will only follow the way
should by the prophet as the Holy Quran
says hope the
question the next question is from
Brother redwan a Hamid
K assalamu Alum I work in jeda Saudi
Arabia once I called a Muslim Filipino
friend of mine for Salah he said I have
offered Salah in holy Caba many times
and one prayer in holy Caba
is equal to one lakh
times therefore there is no need for me
to offer Salah for the next few
years how shall I answer
him as a question that when he was in
Saudi Arabia one of his Filipino friend
when he called him Salah he said that he
had offered Salah in the M Haram in
makah and equivalent to one lakh times
100,000 times therefore I need not offer
for a couple of years part of his
statement was right that there
are in which the prophet said that
offering Salah in M the prophet's mosque
in Madina is equivalent to 1,000 times
than any other mosque except the holy
mosque in Makkah and if anyone offers
Salah in the Holy mosque in Makkah it is
equivalent to 100,000 times
of prayer offers in any other mosque
this is a and agree with it but people
have failed to understand its
context these Saab that you get are the
additional Saabs which you get it
doesn't substitute for any of your other
Salah the prophet didn't say that if you
offer one F Salah is equal to 100,000
Salah offered somewhere no in
Saab in getting blessings you will get
100,000 times that does not mean that
you can miss 100,000 F in your life that
doesn't mean that and to give you an
example for a better understanding how
when we appear for examination you know
we have that you get bonus marks if you
play cricket you get five marks extra
for those people who on admission
Medical College enging colleges they
have a few marks reserved for NCC for
sports for badminton for football if you
take part in inter Colgate cricket match
football match you get those additional
three or four or five marks but if
someone
says this is helpful if you want
admission in a Medical College where you
require 95% marks if you get 94 and a
half these few marks is helpful for you
to get admission in a medical college
but if someone says I will only play
cricket throughout the day throughout
the year throughout my life and 5555
marks extra I'll get 100 marks and then
get admission to a medical college do
you think you'll
get he plays Cricket day and night night
Cricket day cricket full day full night
full year 10 years and then he goes to
the exam and says see I've played so
much Cricket see this cricket match
bonus marks that okay besides the main
examination you're getting additional
marks for doing something else so these
you will get Saab you'll get blessings
but these blessings don't substitute the
far which you have to do
it only comes into consideration when
you have offered the F these are bonus
marks so if a person
offers a Salah in
M he will get multiple time but it will
not substitute for the first Salah he
has to offer every day throughout his
life hope that answer the
[Applause]
question I'm Mr mahes Met uh uh I a
businessman so people who are going in a
mosque here in India it is compulsory to
wear a mosque
cap but in Iran and moroco the people
who are going in the BS they are not
wearing the cap or they are not covering
their head
why the brother as a question that in
India people normally wear the cap when
they go to the mask but when he went to
Iran and Morocco Etc people don't wear
the cap when they offer Salah brother
there's no verse in the Holy Quran or
the authentic Hadi which says that
wearing a cap is f is compulsory for
offering Salah no way it is there but
there are say we say that the S they did
Cover the head always so in that way if
a person covers the head for respect
alhamdulillah because if you Analyze
That in the Eastern culture in the
Eastern culture for respect we wear the
cap if you go to England they say hello
ma'am and they take out the cap hello
ma'am how are you to take out the cap
that culture is taking out the cap for
respect Eastern culture is wearing the
cap for respect but we Muslims we don't
follow any culture of England or this
because it's a sign of respect and there
are Hadith saying that sahabas they
always covered the head not with a cap
sometime with that cloth if you were
Saudi Arabia Etc but there's no Hadi or
quranic ver which says it is far to wear
a cap if a Muslim offer Salah without a
cap inshallah even that Salah will be
accepted it's not a f but bearing a cap
it's preferable hope the answer the
question next question from the
slip can a non-muslim participate in or
offer
Salah this is from vsj computer
professional the Buddha has posed the
question that can a non-muslim
participate in offering Salah brother if
he really truly wants to participate in
the Salah but naturally first he have to
have IM
so non-muslim who wants to accept
Islam he's most welcome most welcome
your Salah will only be accepted if you
do it with humility and
attentiveness if you have faith in Allah
subhana wa ta'ala a non-muslim can
accept Islam and offer Salah but if he
says no I don't believe in Allah I just
want to do what you're doing he can come
and do but it will be just like another
form of gymnastics for him because
without IM without Iman Salah is useless
who are you praying to so if a
non-muslim accepts Islam and then offer
Salah alhamdulillah it will be accepted
if he doesn't believe in Allah just for
name sake to show to the people as the
Holy Quran says in Surah Mound what do
the worshippers who only pray to be seen
of men and in Surah 4 142 that the
Hypocrites they stand for prayer but not
in earnestness and little do they have
Allah in remembrance so Quran speaks
about mafics which are about natural
nonm Muslims non-muslims can pray but it
will not guide them towards
righteousness they mafic they Hypocrites
hypocrite want to pray can pray it's
only a show for the human being but if
someone accepts Islam and believes Allah
is one and only and he wants to give him
thanks and offer Salah he's most welcome
hope the answer the
question asalam Alum brother can I ask a
question can we offer Salah in the house
of a
non-muslim sister POS a question that
can we offer Salah in a house of a
non-muslim sister as I said earlier our
beloved Prophet said it's mentioned in s
bukari volume number one in the book of
Salah chapter 56 had number 429 that the
whole earth has been made for me and my
followers as a place to offer Salah as a
mid you can offer Salah anywhere in the
world but it should be clean and there
are certain conditions like if you want
to offer Salah nonm Muslim you can offer
see to it that it's a clean place or
take a clean cloth and pray on it see to
it in front of you there nothing to
distract you like an ID or like a
photograph you should have a Sutra as a
beloved Prophet said or you can leave
some space from the wall have a Sutra a
Sutra can can also be a spear it's
mentioned s bukari can also be a spear
so if you fulfill the conditions of
Salah you can very well offer in the
house as long as the place is clean and
in front of you there's no photograph ID
Etc hope that answer the question the
next question on the slip is which is
the most suitable dress for offering
Salah C pajama pant shirt
tie
uh and some other scribbled Etc items
are there kid Dehan
lecturer has a question that which is
the most suitable Dr offering salak Pama
band shirt
Etc the minimum
requirement the part that should be
covered for a woman is the complete body
except the face and the hands up to the
wrist it should be loose it should not
be tight it should not be transparent
all these of hijab for a man it's from n
to the knee minimum minimum otherwise
more part of the body is covered it's
preferable including your shoulder
regarding which is better C Pama or a p
sh TI as long as you fulfill the
criteria the minimum criteria of Salah
which is mentioned
the whichever is comfortable for you can
wear if I ask a westner to wear Kurama
he'll be uncomfortable so while praying
he'll be shifting here and there if you
ask a villager to wear a coat and TI
he's not comfortable so he be like that
like that so as long as you fulfill the
minimum criteria mentioned in the Hadith
very well you can wear any clothes it
should not go against the Sharia if it's
within the clothes of the Shar you can
wear that if it's not for example
wearing a cross you cannot wear those
things which resemble that of the
unbeliever you can't pray wearing a
cross that's Haram but if it doesn't
fall in anything Haram fulfill all the
condition whether we C whether you wear
shirt whether you pant whichever you are
comfortable in you can wear that dress
hope that answer the
[Applause]
question I'm my name is mik chandarana
and I'm a Muslim and I would like to ask
you a question what what is the
difference between the Salah and the
other prayers offered by other religions
the pujas and the masses and is there
anything wrong with the other ways of
prayers other than
Salah the question posed by the brother
is that what is the difference in
offering Salah the way Muslims pray and
the prayer offered by non-muslims like
Puja Etc what the difference but the
major difference is that when we offer
Salah we offer to Allah subhana wa
ta'ala that is almighty
God and we believe in a concept of Allah
subhana wa tala again the concept of
Allah subhana tala I discussed in the
lecture which I had given in B mat the
concept of almighty God in other
religions what they worship what they
call God Almighty we don't consider it
to be almighty God for example if a
person does idol worship what we
consider that the idol they're
worshiping is not almighty
God the idol they're worshiping is not
almighty God and if you read the
scriptures also the Hindu Scriptures it
is against ID worship so what we as a
Muslim should do as the Holy Quran
says come to come in terms as us and you
so if I'm speaking to Hindu and if he
says that what Puja I'm doing in front
of that is it right or wrong so I will
tell him if you read the 32 verse number
three
says of that God you cannot make any
image so what you're doing is wrong it's
mentioned bad Gita chapter number
7: 19 to 23 that all those are
materialistic people they worship Demi
Gods false gods all those who worship
false god yet I will fulfill the desires
all those who worship the false god Dem
Gods I fulfill the desires whoever
worship the false God will go to the
kingdom of false god whoever worships me
the true God they will come to me so I
as a Muslim will educate the non-muslims
that what you are
doing I'm not talking about the Quran it
is even wrong according to your
scriptures according to your scriptures
also the way of worshipping is wrong if
I speak to a Christian he doesn't pray
the way it has been taught in the Bible
the Bible says as I mentioned my talk
all the prophets when they worship they
did the sujud before praying they washed
themselves Moses washed Aaron washed may
peace be upon them all they did the
sujud but today when the Christian
worship they don't wash themselves they
don't do the sujud so first I will tell
them what they're not following
according to their scripture which is
correct after that I will tell that this
is the last and final revelation of
Allah subhana tala and shows you the
best way of offering
Salah and there are people who give
counterargument that why do they do idol
worship Etc which has been discussed in
my earlier lecture concept of God in the
major world religion we can refer to
that cassette for the complete answer
hope that answer the
[Applause]
question next question from tanim M K
student of standard 8th as you said
namas should be said shoulder to-
shoulder should women also do the
same
brother has a question as mentioned the
Hadith that our beloved Prophet said
when you stand for Salah stand shoulder
Tosh shoulder should the woman also do
the
same as I mentioned that women allowed
in the mosque but if you say that man
and woman will stand shoulder to
shoulder that's not true but Medical
Science tells us today that the woman it
has got one degree high temperature
you'll feel soft you will consider more
on her than Allah tala so men and men
stand they stand shoulder to shoulder
when women and women stand they stand
shoulder to shoulder but there should be
segregation of the sex and all the other
criteria of Salah is the same for men
and women but they should be equal and
separate facilities hope the answer the
[Applause]
question if you have any further
questions on this subject or on Islam
and comparative religion you are most
welcome to attend our lectures followed
by question and answer sessions every
Saturday at 300 p.m. every Sunday at
10:30 a.m. and every Monday for ladies
at 300 p.m. at the Islamic Research
Foundation
Auditorium the last question for the day
assalamu alaykum brother I as you said
that ladies are allowed to pray in the
Masjid alhamdulillah but I wanted to ask
you because Raman Sharif is coming and
we want to derive the best benefits of
it so suppose like the after Isha we
can't go due to some family problems or
reasons to the Masjid so if we pray
after is 20 raat na that we can't offer
the Quran with the namas so is it the
same or should we try to go to the
Masjid it's if it's
better a question that when Raman is
approaching and
offering after Isa due to family problem
they can't go to the mosque and
alhamdulillah there are quite a few
places nowadays in Bombay itself which
have t for the ladies alhamdulillah you
can inquire which the places are there
there are many alhamdulillah but if you
can't go can you offer at home yes
sister you can preferable is
congregation but if offer congregation
due to certain reasons you can offer
individually regarding is theab same but
natural there you get more guidance you
hear the recitation of the whole Quran
and if you're not Quran but natural you
will not be able to recite the full
Quran in the T but offering at home is
better than not offering at all
regarding Saab will be congregation Saab
according to our beloved Prophet mention
s bukari volume number one you get 25
times more Saab or 27 times more Saab so
in congregation get much more Saab than
than offering a Salah individually hope
that answerers the
[Applause]
question we thank Allah subhana ta'ala
for making this program possible on
behalf of the Islamic Research
Foundation I thank all our guests
including the press for attending the
program we also appreciate and thank all
the persons involved in the organizing
and recording of this event for their
dedicated efforts in the success of this
program
[Music]
the last and
final prophet of
Allah he was a
mercy unto the
[Music]
universe peace and blessings
be he
began this perfect
man sending his
word across the
land leading
only